so I want you to think back to tuesday
in particular I want you to remember we
defined this in a geometric way right
and if you see this is equal to some
number over here likes a fine how do you
read that how do you geometrically
explain what's going on what shade you
get you get a circle okay and the reason
why is because you're measuring a
distance from the origin and you're
saying I want that distance to always be
the same number right and that traces
out though that's the radius then okay
so there's your circle then we extended
that just a teeny little bit and we said
I'll okay well if you introduce if you
throw an extra like a number in here
another complex number okay you're still
measuring a distance still measuring
distance but what's the difference yeah
very good instead of measuring from the
origin from the Orangemen right you're
measuring from w that's a new point of
reference as of work right you still
have a radius of 5 but your circles now
moved somewhere else okay so that's sort
of the the piece of knowledge you need
to call on then when you look at this
right so you can see this is still going
to be a circle what can you tell me
about the circle
the center I heard two things the two
facts that I did okay the radius is
going to be younger just read off the
readies it's right there ok and then
where is the center going to be yeah to
puts too much so the first thing I want
to do as I solve this question is I'm
just going to rewrite that in the right
form to make it a little more obvious
this is modulus of z minus and then I
provide my points I've got to take that-
that- out so that's going to be 2 plus
2i as you as you suggested okay so
there's my point of reference and here
is the radius I'm interested okay
alright so now I've got a sort of a
rough picture in my head then I have a
look at the question find the range of
what said and find a range of odds here
okay so you can see part of the theme of
consumer theme of this morning's graphs
last time we focus on distances today
we're going to focus on arguments we
want to find okay what's the biggest
mods it can be and what's the smallest
thing can be that's that's the range
right and what's the biggest this can be
what's the s'mores that can be so
clearly I need a picture all right so
we're going to answer this question on
the basis of this picture in fact
because there are two vids I'm actually
this is going to be easiest for you to
understand if we draw 27 pictures the
same graph but we're going to use one to
do this one and then the other one to
use this one you can't use the one
diagram if you're really cheap but it's
going to get confusing it's going to way
too many lines on there and let's let's
do this right so think about what that
looks like try get the scale reasonable
think about this right you know where
this is let's start to draw us together
2+2 I that tells you go to it this way
one two and then go to you up to so now
I know ok there's my center right now
your radius of route to what is Roo to
roughly you only need to do roughly
about 1.4 ok so if like if I go this
that's one away from the center 1.4 is
going to be like nothing we further ok
so a point like that that's going to be
on the circumference I can make the same
argument going daddy I can go 1.4 it's
gonna be about there there is a booth
for the circumference and now I can sort
of trays out my circle with a better
life for Michael to go on ok so you've
got to circle you've got a rough idea
drop me a pair of those because we're
going to use one of them to find the
range of my dad and the other one to
find the range of our said go ahead
let's do these one at home right so I've
got my rough picture I should probably
put some extra details of you because
I've said this guy up here is two plus
two I it's a bad first to write it
that's where that is right I also know
where the radii I they will come in in a
second this first one let's have a think
about what they're ok now look at the
geometry of this the question we're
trying to answer is what's the smallest
ones it could possibly be Alan's the
largest ok now have a look at the
diagram the smallest value of mod Z is
that all of these this is so we've drawn
out it's all the Possible's ads then can
be anywhere on the circumference of the
circle ok now which of those ends is
closest to the origin just look at it
geometrically right you can see when you
think about things in terms of like just
straight lines you know the shortest
distance from a point to a straight line
is the perpendicular distance right the
perpendicular now this is not a straight
line but because of what we know from
calculus way you can kind of treat this
service like a straight line at an
infinite series of points ok now where
would be the closest perpendicular
distance just have a look at it do you
not think it would be that spot right
there right it's like look I'm trying to
cross through it and try to get there as
quickly as a possible care if I sort of
do after this over here you can see the
line literally gets longer and longer
and longer does that make sense and of
course if I cross over to the other side
of this world there's no point doing
that okay so I want one of these kinds
of lines if I go straight there in a
perpendicular sort of direction I'll be
fine right so how do I get this distance
right well let's see how wellness tracks
along there's where I can't my dots okay
let's reconnect with us and that point
there that I'm interested in I think
that's the closest right and I can
actually prove that you immeasurably but
looking at this question this is not a
primitive question it's enough to be
able to understand what's going on get a
sense of it from my graph because
graphing is a superpower and then use
the geometry heater wakeups going on if
this is two plus two I and I know the
radius of this circle to how can I use
that to find out where that point is
because once I know where the point is
finding the modulus is very easy sorry I
heard some I said some babe you too
steep answers then you want to brave it
up to actually this might actually work
okay so if I like two plus 2i minus root
to think about this right rutu just on
its own is a real number this is just a
real number so if I took this number and
subtracted a real number on the complex
plane real numbers tell me about
horizontal displacement where am I
horizontally so 2 plus 2i minus root 2
is going to take you from here root 2 in
that direction right in fact 2 plus 2i
minus root 2 is this point right here
which is a good point but it's not the
point of after what else we do have
would be x squared
violence route 26 when people stream 2
and 1 B 2 ok alright so here we go this
way right remember i just want mods in i
just want this distance right now I know
what this distance it's like I can find
that out right that's just Pythagoras
that's just you know it's x squared Y
squared take a square root well you just
need to subtract that from here this is
just a straight lining do you see that
here's another way that I could think
about it here's a right angle triangle
they're right for triangles they get
into everything like soon so if the
paint if the arm if this angle over here
so its hypotenuse over here is root 2
and keep in mind like 2+2 irate took us
to a what is the argument opportu 2+2 I
this angle in me this is PI over 4 45
degrees isn't it that's plan for then
that's fine form if the tax plan for
that's plan for sure what kind of
triangle is this it's not as right
angles it's also isosceles so these two
sides are the same something squared for
something squared over that squared
pretty sure that's the 11 route to
triangle that you use for like your
exact ratio for the tree right so if
this is one down and one across then
what are the coordinates of this point
from chicken stew I that means discovery
1 plus my name is it like there's to
pursue are you went down that menu took
away my you went to the left means you
to go anyone I'm happy with that because
that isn't now by the same arguing
because in fact I've got congruence I
now know what this argument here sorry
this modulus is here right it is the
same triangle I could draw another one
right there it is Stuart st. dimensions
so therefore the smallest distance the
minimum value of mods air is going to be
root 2 are you happy with the way that I
did that because that make sense now you
can thank you very quickly based on all
that geometric work on where the
furthest distance will be where am I
going to go I'm going to go right across
the opposite side of the circle right
back
I'm just going to extend this line okay
it's a bit wonky but you got a deal okay
again not by coincidence it's the same 1
102 triangle over here I don't even need
some time it's very easy to work out the
best 3 plus 3 I but I don't even care
it's 2 plus 3i you can see the distance
is going to be 1 2 3 lots of Row 2 does
that make sense so therefore off of that
he's a smallest intervene he's the
biggest it can be so root 2 must be less
than or equal to 1 said which is less
than or equal to ok that's the range
right you're used to thinking of range
just about y values but range can refer
to anything you like you just want the
biggest to smallest things you can
possibly be right does he know any
questions on their trail off what do you
mean by trail off like why are you stuff
there uh stop wearing like a peon like
as in why don't I background oh I see
okay so the whole idea is it's a great
question when I say if this right what
that means is I can't go anywhere on the
complex plane I can only go Zed can only
go on the place in the complex plane
that obey these rules right and we we
saw from last week oh well this gives us
a circle so that means all the the Zed's
that can exist all exist on this circle
Zeb can't be here or here or here or
here for that matter okay so the only
says that can be useful to me other ones
on the circumference of this circle so
that's why this lines either just go on
forever cuz then can never ever be here
it's not on the circle okay good
question okay now I held your hand a lot
to help you work out the genome through
this and therefore how I approach this
let me give you a few moments to get a
head start on me because we're thinking
that angles there's going to be some
different argument required but again
you've got the diagram you can see what
I meant by by if they busy okay think
again where might you go if you were
trying to minimize not a distance but an
argument right like pick a point on the
circle and think about it in an easy one
this one which we already know okay so
we know the argument of that particular
Z is planned for but I reckon you could
get a smaller argument that right like
you can see parts on the circle points
on the circle that have a smaller
argument and you can see once which have
a bigger argument where would you go on
the circle have a go give it two or
three minutes to scroll on your diagram
and try and make an argument